once again the astrazeneca vaccine is
under the spotlight
denmark has paused roll out of the jab
for 14 days as a precaution
following reports that one person
suffered a blood clot shortly after
having a dose
and subsequently died austria has also
taken action after someone developed
multiple clots
and died 10 days after vaccination
another person was hospitalized after
suffering a clot on the lung
but is recovering the austrian health
authority has suspended
one batch of the vaccine according to
the european medicines agency the batch
in question
is abv 5300 one
million doses from the batch were
delivered to 17
countries at least nine have so far
suspended some
or all of the vaccine the medical
regulator says that
as of wednesday close to 5 million
people across the eu
have had the astrazeneca vaccine with 30
cases of blood clots but that's no
higher than the rate
in the general unvaccinated population
here in the uk just over 23 million
people have so far had at least
one dose of a covid vaccine 11 million
have had the astrazeneca oxford jab
according to the latest statistics from
the uk medical regulator the mhra
there have been just over 54 000 side
effects following immunization with the
astrazeneca vaccine
and a little over 33 000 with a fisa jab
by far the most common side effects are
pain at the injection site
headaches chills and fatigue there's no
increased rate of blood clots following
vaccination
experts say the european reaction has
been disproportionate
when we see these kinds of stories we
all of course
start to worry is this a real problem
and in my view we don't have enough
evidence at all to conclude that yet and
so
i would just want to be very wary that
we don't put people off from taking the
vaccine
when we know for sure that it will
prevent
severe coveted illness and death these
are
new vaccines and medical staff are hyper
vigilant for
anything unusual there's nothing to
suggest a causal link between
clots and the vaccine so there seems no
reason to be worried about
either vaccine being used in the uk
rollout